aside from a role that was largely cut
out of 2001's Legally Blonde actor
Cheney clay applied his trade in TV for
the bulk of his career his lengthiest
gig was as a recurring character officer
Asher on the shield appearing on 16
episodes of the award-winning FX police
drama with some airing after his 2007
death Asher was notable for being one of
the only characters on the show that had
seemingly earned the trust of Vic Macky
clay seemed to be carving out a niche on
cop shows also Landing guest star roles
on CSI Cold Case and as an FBI agent on
Las Vegas he popped up early in the Run
of NCIS playing Corporal Paul Brinkman
in the show's second episode clay
tragically passed away in July 2007 at
just 34 the result of complications from
sleep apnea according to his memorial
page his final completed role was in the
movie oneway to Valhalla released 2
years after his death